as Vlad mentioned earlier we have a
developing story concerning the possible
mishandling of classified information
first reported by CBS News the justice
department is overseeing a review of
roughly 10 documents marked classified
they were found in an office space that
President Biden used before he was
elected the documents come from Mr
Biden's time as vice president and their
exact nature and level of classification
is unclear Adriana Diaz was first to
report this story Adriana Ramona good
morning three sources confirmed this
story to our CBS News team now a
preliminary inquiry by the justice
department is nearing its conclusion but
as soon as we broke this news it set off
a political Firestorm with Republicans
who now control the House of
Representatives and they are asking for
answers
CBS News learned roughly 10 documents
marked classified were found inside this
former office of President Biden right
across from the U.S Capitol sources told
CBS News the justice department launched
the review Into the matter after the
president's personal lawyers found a
small number of documents with
classified markings in a locked closet
according to a White House lawyer the
documents were discovered in early
November while the attorneys were
packing up the office at the Penn Biden
Center a foreign policy Research
Institute that the White House said Mr
Biden used as an office periodically
from 2017 until the start of the 2020
campaign the White House council's
Office says the documents were not the
subject of any previous request by The
Archives and that it immediately
reported the discovery to the National
Archives which took possession of the
documents the following day then
attorney general Merrick Garland asked
the U.S attorney in Chicago John lausch
a trump appointee to review the matter
and report back the FBI is also involved
in the preliminary inquiry according to
a source the docume did not contain
nuclear secrets but their exact nature
and classification level are unclear the
new Republican Speaker of the House
called The Discovery
as other GOP lawmakers demanded answers
maybe the American people should have a
right to know about it as well so but
we'll have to see what these 10
documents are it is illegal to keep
classified material in an unsecured
location but sources say it is not clear
whether any crime occurred or if anyone
will face charges if there was some
other
nefarious purpose or criminal intent
behind that that remains to be seen but
this just could be a case of sloppy
record keeping the classified documents
in Mr Biden's former office were
discovered on November 2nd about three
months after the FBI executed a search
warrant at former president Trump's
Florida home and office that's after he
refused to comply with repeated requests
to return the materials FBI agents laid
out on the floor some of the more than
100 seized documents marked classify
fight President Biden was critical when
he spoke to Scott Pelley in September
for 60 minutes how that could possibly
happen how one anyone could be that
irresponsible former Federal prosecutor
Scott Fredrickson says there are key
differences between the Biden inquiry
and that involving former president
Trump how significant is it that these
documents were self-reported voluntarily
turned over I think the self-reporting
here is probably the single most
important part of this situation it
indicates a lack of intentional conduct
it's completely different from the
Mar-A-Lago case which tends based on
reporting to indicate there was
intentionally
activity to take those documents but
Monday night in a post Trump asked when
is the FBI going to raid the many homes
of Joe Biden perhaps even the White
House
a source familiar with the review tell
CBS News the documents are currently
located in a secured government facility
known as a skiff here in Washington once
the attorney general reviews the inquiry
he will then decide whether there should
be a criminal investigation by the FBI
or even a special counsel Gail
oh boy Adriana I'm still wondering if
anything is marked classified how it
leaves the White House to begin with but
that's a whole other story I'm I'm sure
but as you just pointed out there is a
difference between the former
president's situation and this one but
are there any pieces that were still
missing
there are girl we still don't know what
the information was in those documents
how sensitive are they what is their
level of classification and also how
they got to the Penn Biden Center
whether or not that was intentional will
be key in determining any potential
criminality
all right more to come on this for sure
Adriana thank you